and
democrats
came out after of course all the
spotlight's been on joe manchin this
week
and said
we're going to play hardball with him
next year
yep
joe biden president joe biden says he is
not done with his talks with joe manchin
this isn't over they're going to
continue on with this chuck schumer says
we're going to play hardball
with joe manchin
we're going to make this thing happen
and they're gonna start putting pressure
on him
and that's what's been needed this whole
time i want everybody to think for a
second
in terms of in the senate
who are the people you have seen
publicly come out
and call out joe manchin who are sitting
in the senate today well not today
they're on vacation but you know what i
mean
who
chuck schumer has
bernie sanders has
pretty sure elizabeth warren has
it's three
three out of three out of 50
that i know of
now that's not to say they're the only
three
sure plenty of other folks could have
flown under the radar maybe their
statements their comments didn't quite
get the attention that the comments of
these other folks had
but why
and bernie sanders made headlines for a
day and a half last week by saying joe
manchin and kirsten sinema were acting
like republicans
but part of the pressure campaign that
has to be put on joe manchin the hard
ball the democrats say they're gonna
play
means that it can't just be bernie
sanders they can't just send bernie out
to be the attack dog and then later on
be like well he's not really a democrat
so that's why he can do it no
bernie sanders is more of a democrat
than joe manchin could ever hope to be
in his life trust me
in fact he's more of a democrat than any
of the democrats in that synod but
either way
you can't just have one guy you can't
have three people
elizabeth warren is tough she is
absolutely
just
an attack person
and a passionate person and i love
elizabeth warren
but that's also not enough
there has to be this united front
and that's what the democratic party has
been lacking
you know sure you're not going to get
cinema to join in on the attacks on joe
manchin to to really pressure him you're
not going to get
tester to do it either
but you can get a handful
you know 10 to 15 other
democratic senators to band together
and go public with this and that's what
you have to do
it can't just be one guy doing an
interview here elizabeth warren doing an
interview over here and you know making
passing comments about joe manchin and
both of them and then the interviewer
moves on to something else that's not
good enough
it has to be press conferences
it has to be meetings
and then after the meetings you have to
do another press conference and talk
about how he wouldn't
go along with what you needed and how
much that's going to harm the people of
the united states
those are the points you hit on
you don't just talk about oh everybody's
going to suffer by this no say listen
because of this man obstructing this
legislation you don't get that child tax
credit money in your bank every month
anymore
because of his decision here we're not
going to have
child care expenses paid for for you
we're not going to have lower cost
prescription prescription drugs we're
not going to have the 35 insulin that's
a part of the legislation
we're not going to transition to
renewable energy we're going to keep
burning the dirty fossil fuels
that's the message you go forward with
but you have to go forward with it
with as united of a front as you can put
together
it can't be a piecemeal patchwork of one
senator over here on msnbc saying it
went on cnn saying it and then nobody
talks about it for another month no
and you can't put it all on joe biden
either
it can't just be manchin and biden
talking again no
it has to be everybody everywhere every
time all the time
going after him and playing hardball so
again the democrats say
they're going to play hardball with joe
manchin in 2022 and i am here for it all
day long
but you have to do it right
you can't just come across as a bunch of
bullies who are mad at mansion
put the real pressure on him remind the
public of what's at stake
and eventually if you're united and
strong
you might just be able to crack him
i'm farron cousins you can find me on
youtube at youtube.com fair and balanced
youtube.com
the ring of fire and ring of fire
podcast at rofpodcast.com
i'll be right back with more on the
david pakman show